bien ahora vamos a la parte se conduce
una bicicleta por el mismo camino para
hacer un menor o igual que te menor o
igual que 40 la velocidad de voz está
modelada por y aquí dice vettel es igual
a de kubica
menos seis de cuadrada más trescientos
donde te está dado en minutos y pdte me
está dado en metros por minuto
encuentra la aceleración de voz en el
tiempo te igual a cinco bueno si esta es
la función velocidad ésta que tenemos
aquí nosotros lo que vamos a querer es
encontrar la aceleración que es la
derivada de la función velocidad con
respecto al tiempo es decir la tasa de
cambio de la velocidad con respecto al
tiempo
esa es la aceleración y después queremos
encontrar esa aceleración en el tiempo
de igual a 5 dicho otra manera lo que
estamos buscando
prima de 5 esto es lo que estamos
buscando así que primero qué te parece
si encontramos cuánto vale de prima de
té y de prima de tema va a ser lo mismo
que la derivada de esta expresión que
tengo aquí y si observas esto es
simplemente aplicar las reglas de la
potencia y me va a quedar la derivada de
te ubican estrés de cuadrada muy bien y
después tengo la derivada de menos 6 de
cuadrada bajamos la potencia y me queda
6 por 2 lo cual es 12 menos 12 t menos
27 y por último tengo la derivada de 300
bueno la derivada de una constante 0
porque 300 no va a cambiar con respecto
al tiempo y entonces mi derivada es
justo está 3 t cuadrada menos 2
y lo que nosotros queremos es evaluar
esta derivada en el valor de t igual a 5
así que vamos a hacerlo me va a quedar 3
por 5 elevado al cuadrado menos 12 por 5
ok esto es tan sencillo 5 al 4 a 225 por
tres es 75 me queda 75 menos 60 y bueno
esto es lo mismo que 15 entonces mi
resultado es 15 y si queremos escribirlo
en las unidades correctas observa que la
velocidad está dada en metros por minuto
y el tiempo está dado en minutos
entonces me va a quedar metros por
minuto por minuto eso es lo mismo que
metros
sobre minuto elevado al cuadrado
minuto elevado al cuadrado así que con
esta respuesta vámonos al inciso de dice
con base en el modelo b del inciso c con
este modelo de aquí encuentra la
velocidad promedio de voz en el
intervalo 0 menor o igual que t menor o
igual que 10 ahora bien si el concepto o
la idea de velocidad promedio es
completamente desconocida para ti y no
recuerdas que es el promedio de una
función entonces te recomiendo que veas
los vídeos y los ejercicios de la canaca
de min
que hay sobre este tema el promedio de
una función pero regresando al problema
lo que buscamos es la velocidad promedio
y ésta va a ser el área entre la curva
velocidad y el eje del tiempo dividida
entre el tiempo total es decir entre el
cambio en el tiempo
entonces me va a quedar que la velocidad
promedio déjame notarlo aquí
y dejad promedio
promedio va a ser igual a el área entre
la curva velocidad y el eje lo cual es
la integral desde el tiempo de igual a
cero hasta el tiempo de igual a 10 muy
bien de la función vedette y esto
dt ya esto lo vamos a dividir entre el
cambio en el tiempo es decir si tenemos
desde el tiempo te iguala 10 hasta el
tiempo te iguala 0 tenemos un cambio en
el tiempo de 10 minutos y la intuición
detrás de esto es que si tú tienes el
área de algo y quieres encontrar su
altura promedio entonces simplemente
tienes que dividirlo entre el ancho y
eso es justo lo que estamos haciendo
aquí si sabemos el área de algo y
queremos encontrar su altura promedio
entonces vamos a dividir entre él
y al final de ahí viene la intuición de
dónde sale esta expresión así que esto
va a ser igual a un décimo que
multiplica a la integral de 0 a 10 de
bueno esta función que tengo aquí la
función de kubica de kubica menos seis
de cuadrada ya esto le sumamos 300 esto
dt
bien y esto va a ser exactamente igual
que un 10º 11º y bueno cual es la anti
derivada de t kubica
eso va a ser lo mismo que t 4a entre 4
de 4a
entre 4 y si ahora nos preguntamos cuál
es la anti derivada de menos 6 de
cuadrada bueno la anti derivada de t
cuadrada este pública entre 3 entonces
menos 6 entre 3 me queda menos 2
de kubica y por último tengo la antes
derivada de 300 lo cual es 300
muy bien y quiero que esto de aquí lo
evaluamos lo vamos a evaluar primero en
10 y a esto le vamos a quitar la
evaluación en 0 así que si bajamos un
poco esta pantalla para terminar este
problema esto me va a quedar de la
siguiente manera esto es lo mismo que un
décimo y primero vamos a evaluar en 10
me va a quedar 10 elevado a la cuarta
potencia bueno es 10 100 mil diez mil
10.000 entre 4 es 2500 2500 ya esto le
voy a quitar y después dicen 10 elevado
al cubo es 1000 por 2 me queda 2000 2000
muy bien ya esto le voy a sumar 300 por
10 lo cual es 3000
muy bien y a todo esto le voy a quitar
la evaluación en cero pero si observas
será la cuarta es 0 100 y 300 por 0 0
así que simplemente voy a cerrar este
paréntesis porque no tenemos que
quitarle nada y ahora sí 2500 menos
2.500 más 3000 me va a quedar que todo
esto que tengo aquí es lo mismo que 3500
3500 y si a esto lo divido entre 10 me
queda 350 de lujo 350 y como estoy
hablando de velocidad promedio va a ser
350 metros por mí
y ya está con esto hemos acabado este
problema